our main story tonight concerns
political fundraising and before you
roll your eyes this is not going to be
about how money corrupts presidential
candidates for that you can read much
more on your most annoying friends
Facebook posts dan that is a comment on
a picture of a baby what the is
wrong with you take it down I would like
to talk instead about congressional
fundraising which is much less covered
but no less astonishing in the 2014
election cycle candidates for the House
and Senate raiser combined 1.7 billion
dollars that's a lot of money that's
more than it costs to buy two hundred
and thirty million choose of
hemorrhoidal cooling gel and it's
somehow even more upsetting
now now interestingly much of that money
has to be raised one way or another by
the politicians themselves which they
have complained about for years and and
say that it can be the worst part of
their job you know I hated raising money
hated it it's painful frankly ah
they continually ask people for money if
Donna and I could tell you how many
hours we spend with our good colleagues
on our side of the issues talking about
raising money it would be an
embarrassment because it is an
embarrassment Wow an embarrassment that
is a strong statement although he might
be overestimating Congress's capacity
for embarrassment because bear in mind
we are talking about a place where these
moments happened do you like green eggs
and ham I do not like them sam-i-am I do
not like green eggs and ham two bits
four bits six bits a dollar all for the
Gators stand up in holler go Gators meet
the Mets meet the Mets step right up and
greet the Mets don't know much about
chemistry don't know much toxicology
don't know what's ammonium nitrate
except it's easy to detonate but I do
know that ist was used to increase our
security
what a much safer world this could be
don't know much about gas burn oh my god
what is most shocking about that last
clip is that he read the room and
decided you know what I think they want
to hear another verse I think I think
I'm gonna do another verse here I'm
reading this room and I'm doing it but
look the sheer amount of time
politicians spend fundraising is not
just embarrassing it's horrifying
some say the members can spend anywhere
from 25 to 50 percent of their time on
it but former Senate Majority Leader Tom
Daschle once guessed that in the two
years before an election senators can
spend two thirds of their time raising
money and if two-thirds of the work you
do is strictly about the money
you're not a legislator you're Robert
DeNiro at that point so so tonight
tonight let's look at where that time
actually goes and let's begin with the
most obvious form of fundraising
fundraisers these are usually shitty
parties in DC bars restaurants or town
houses and there are a lot of them the
Sunlight Foundation estimates that in
the last election cycle members of
Congress held over 2,800 fundraisers
Washington is like Rod Stewart's haircut
party in the front party in the back
frankly too much party and no business
anywhere to be found
fundraisers are so ubiquitous in DC you
could conceivably construct a whole day
around them which is exactly what former
Eyal representative Bruce Braley did on
September 20 2012 when 8:30 a.m. he held
a fundraising breakfast followed at noon
by a fundraising lunch and ending with a
fundraising evening reception by that
time he was less a member of Congress
than he was a sentient storage container
for canapes in fact fundraisers are such
an integral part of DC's economy some
restaurants derive a decent chunk of
their income just from hosting them look
at Johnny's half shell it's a seafood
restaurant just blocks from the Capitol
in the past 10 years a whopping 948
Congressional fundraisers have been held
there it is almost inevitable that your
elected representative will have spent
at least some time in a place that
market itself thusly champagne and
oysters of Johnny's loose to Johnny's
crappy to the quieter the happy out gift
of the hot shell crabs of Johnny Sack
shell on the terrace
previous to you and your tiny choice
after piece he is a significant figure
in DC influential decisions are being
made under the watchful eye of a man who
looks like Jon Bon Jovi's less talented
step cousin Jim Bon Jovi
so some politicians even turned their
own personal milestones into fundraising
opportunities like Republican Andy Barr
who held a 41st birthday fundraiser
which cost a minimum of $500 per person
to attend or theirs
Florida representative Ileana Ross
laitanan who turned her 30th wedding
anniversary into a fund raiser an event
that is almost breathtaking in its
sadness because a 30th wedding
anniversary should not be about raising
political capital it should be about
eating a largely silent dinner
killing two bottles of wine forgetting
to have sex and falling asleep to our
friends rerun all of the anniversary and
do it right and it in perhaps the most
pathetic bid for hypnose available many
members of Congress will even staged
fundraisers at pop concerts the power of
Taylor Swift not only changes the music
business it makes money and so much so
that some of washington's elites are
capitalizing on the pop princesses 1989
tour which stops over in DC tonight we
have over 10 Republicans five Democrats
three packs all raising money off this
Taylor Swift concert tickets going into
thousands upon thousands of dollars some
of these members we spoke to
specifically representative buyer of
Virginia who's having a fundraiser he
goes his daughter turned him on to
Taylor Swift he likes her feminist
lyrics and that is why they're moving
forward it's true
representative Don Beyer held a
fundraiser at a Taylor Swift concert and
I don't know about you but this man is
not feeling 22 he is feeling and looking
very much 65 but but amazingly all of
this is glamorous compared to the hours
and hours that politicians spent
fundraising over the phone a few years
ago a PowerPoint presentation from the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee two freshmen lawmakers leaked
and it was showing their model schedule
which suggested four hours a day of call
time four hours on the phone the only
time that makes sense is if you're
trying to have phone sex with sting
have you come yet huh it's been three
hours have you come yet I've got stuff
to do Gordon this can't be my day and
look horrendously lawmakers have even
been pulled out of hearings to go do
that call time the first week I was down
here we were having a committee hearing
in education and my chief of staff at
that time came in and said you have to
leave you know we went into a V ante
room and I said we don't have to go and
she goes you have to go make phone calls
and I looked at everyone this is my
first hearing and you're coming in and
asking me to leave how am I going to
learn anything exactly she was a rookie
legislator she needed to learn how to do
her job the Knicks don't pull rookie
kristaps porzingis out of a game so he
can go make cold calls to season ticket
holders because that would not be the
best use of kristaps porzingis his time
and if you think that sounds like a
dehumanizing process rest assured it is
I felt used when I had to go raise money
I was embarrassed I thought it was ugly
I thought it was demeaning my staff kept
saying you got to go do it I said they
don't like it you get a Rolodex and you
get to go outside the building for a
whole day and dial numbers of jerks
you've never heard of in your whole life
to get money out of them
he's absolutely right if you want to get
money out of a bunch of jerks you've
never heard of before
you shouldn't have to call them on the
phone when you can simply open a vape
shop boom done
done and if you're wondering why he said
he had to go outside the building that's
because according to federal law members
of Congress can't solicit or receive
donations in their offices so each
party's congressional committee has set
up call rooms in their party
headquarters just a few blocks from the
Capitol we couldn't find any footage
from inside those rooms but they sound
pretty grim
they've got cubicles and they've got a
headset and they often have a minder who
sort of sits at their shoulder and make
sure that they don't take too
on each call they say that the building
can really start to stink after a while
after a few hours it starts to smell
like a locker room yeah but but what do
you expect half the people in that room
probably spent their morning slurping
down Easter's in an 80s hockey player's
sweaty crap Shack and just about all
lawmakers have to do this even those
like Eleanor Holmes Norton in
ludicrously safe seats she regularly
gets reelected with over 80 percent of
the vote but despite that roughly six
years ago she wound up leaving this
voicemail for a lobbyist I was frankly
surprised to see that we don't have a
record so far as I can tell of your
having given to me despite my long and
deep work in fact it's been my major
work on the committee and subcommittees
been essentially in your sector
I'm simply candidly calling to ask for
contribution that is so depressing to
hear even before you think about her
calling from a room filled with the odor
of Steny Hoyer shrimp burps and remember
her seat is safe it's so safe she barely
needs campaign funds for herself
the problem is members are still
expected to pay dues to their own party
which can then be distributed to
candidates in tougher races BuzzFeed
actually got its hands on a d-triple-c
spreadsheet two years ago showing the
amount of money the committee expects
each member to pay with figures ranging
from a hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars at the low end all the way up to
eight hundred thousand dollars at the
top so is it any wonder the politicians
are hitting up their customer base
harder than a Girl Scout with gambling
debts Oh took two boxes of Samoas nah
nah
four boxes four boxes or I walk four
boxes you get four boxes I know where
you live whoopee and if you are
desperately trying to rack up dollars
that can affect the kind of people that
you are targeting on the phone as
Senator Chris Murphy explains for a
Senate race I'm not calling anybody who
doesn't have the chance of giving me at
least $1,000 so you got to imagine that
the people I'm calling you know are
folks that are you know making a half a
million to a million dollars and you
know they have fundamentally different
problems than everybody everybody else
and that is a huge problem because it
cannot help but affect the way you see
the world if you're only calling donors
rich enough that their main concerns are
estate taxes or which Belgian kimono
their cats will wear that day that's a
good choice though but but but to be
fair now to be fair direct fundraising
by candidates is just one part of a
system that also includes super PACs and
so-called dark money although to be even
fairer it is still the largest part and
and regulating campaign finance is going
to be difficult for a start there's the
Supreme Court's 1976 buckley versus
vallejo decision which basically held
that spending money is a form of speech
and sure there are times when that's
probably true for example a 50 year old
man spending money on a convertible is
loudly saying I would like to sexually
disappoint a woman half my age he's and
we're hearing him loud and clear he's
being hurt but but a bigger problem is
that while both sides agree they hate
this neither wants to unilaterally back
down first it's basically a cold war but
worse because at least in the real Cold
War we got a trip to the moon and the
third best rocky villain out of it which
is not to say that there are not some
attempts to address parts of the problem
Democrats have pushed the disclose Act
which would force more transparency on
dark money and one Republican
congressman has something called the
stop act which will prohibit members of
members of Congress from personally
asking for donations but those would be
very small fixes now a larger idea is
perhaps the government by the People Act
which would give tax credits and provide
public funding for candidates by
matching small donations and a ratio of
at least six to one but before you get
too excited about that idea to slight
caveats first we asked and it would cost
an estimated 500 million dollars a year
which is a lot and second gov track
taught us which offers predictions on
whether bills are likely to pass gives
it a 0% chance in our current Congress
just flat zero which kind of makes you
wonder if they try to find something
more harsh than zero like negative zero
or oh hell zero or just a zero with a
frowny face in it and that's a bit
frustrating because remember people in
Congress are the ones constantly
complaining about the time that they are
forced to waste on fund raising in fact
Steve Israel a Democrat from Long Island
announced his retirement at the
beginning of this year saying I don't
think I can spend another day in another
call room making another call begging
for money and since he is leaving anyway
I figured he might be willing to shine a
light on some of the aspects of fund
raising that we don't usually see so I
sat down with Steve Israel last week
take a look congressman thank you so
much for agreeing to talk with me thank
you so let's start with political
fundraising in your prime how many of
those fundraisers were you physically
having to go to a year so all told over
16 years I've done just for my own
re-election 1,600 fundraising events
home Ashley
fans that's one every three days more or
less over 16 years yeah yeah that's a
lot I'm gonna say three words to you
congressman
Johnny's half-shell I know it well
oh yeah no you do yeah what's it
like in there it is like look it's like
any restaurant in America which has lots
of people in suits raising money
differences you have candidates and
members of Congress and supporters who
are contributing $1,000 for the
privilege of having some shellfish it's
just it's interesting to me it's like
how every working Congress person in
this city has a basic understanding of
Johnny's half-shell right I don't think
I've ever had a fundraiser for myself
know you at that restaurant I just don't
remember no in 2011 you had a breakfast
fundraiser at the hard shell that
started at 8:30 a.m. right probably no
one goes to a seafood restaurant at 8:30
in the morning without expecting
something in return no one is saying
what I was gonna be there anyway to have
my bucket of breakfast shrimp I'll swing
by Steve's thing and that is the problem
with the system is that people believe
that if they are in that room having
supported a campaign that they get
access and the case access to Steve
Israel wasn't enticing enough a review
of his fundraiser invites threw up a
common theme some congressmen have
barbecue some have fishing trips what
was your thing I did a long-arm pizza
night but there was another thing to
your fund raisers wasn't yes was what
was it well I think you know what it was
I'm anxious to know you had an annual
Long Island wine trip Long Island wine
tasting in DC Long Island wine and cigar
tasting
I hope those were not Long Island cigars
and an event called Chinese food and
politics where I'm gonna go ahead and
say that you wash down your general
sales chicken with a glass of no no no
you cannot bring wrong our wine to
Chinese food why just just Long Island
why not pair well with it Chinese food
not Washington Chinese what does it pair
well with street violence remapping get
me to say one negative thing about Long
Island I'm very proud of it
but I hadn't come here to talk about
terrible wine I wanted to talk about the
engine-room of congressional fundraising
talk to me about the Congressional call
center how important is that place well
you've got to have a place to make those
calls what does it look like me a word
picture is there you know motivational
posters on the wall saying hang in there
and try not to think too much about what
you're doing you have a bunch of
cubicles set up and those cheap fabric
dividers and you sit at a little desk
and you have a phone and you have an
assistant next to you and you have a
call book and the coal book has sheets
of every donor past donors and their
records and your assistant gets a
supporter on the phone and gives the
phone to you and you engage in polite
conversation and then you get to the
point and then you hang up and then you
flip the page to the next donor and then
you make another call and you continue
doing that until you have the resources
in order to get reelected oh my god
that's depressing not what our founders
had in mind how do you train people to
do it well is there a script like with
small talk and how they could be part of
the solution now so every member has
their own approach my approach was to
get right to the point and then have a
civilized conversation okay I mean I
guess it makes sense it's just like
someone giving you a massage and
starting with the and then
working the shoulders it's fine it's
just unexpected well everybody has their
own style and their own preferences how
much time is there between hanging up
that phone in the next call you got to
keep moving you have to keep moving if
you are in a very competitive district
and you know you've got to raise 1.5
million dollars that means that you have
to raise a certain amount of money every
quarter you break it down to a certain
amount of money every month you break it
down to a certain amount of money every
week and you break it down to a certain
amount of money in every hour of call
time this whole call center sounds like
a shitty telemarketing operation it is a
my view of form of torture and
the real victims of this torture have
become the American people because they
believe that they don't have a voice in
this system now most goods telemarketing
operations have a boss who holds people
speak to the fire and forces them to
make calls and hit their quotas who was
that boss for you well my boss was the
prospect of losing my election to a
Republican who would undo all the work I
did for the middle class
yeah but also I'm gay as the prospect
okay before that you were the chairman
oh I'm sorry yes so I was the chairman
the Democratic campaign team so you were
that boss you were the one pushing
people to hit quotas
I had a responsibility to tell them you
need to spend time raising money to come
to Washington to change the system and
he must have told them that a lot
because in Steve Israel's time as
chairman he managed to push members of
the d-triple-c to hit record fundraising
levels we out raised the NRCC by sixteen
point two million dollars that's never
happened before and it can't have been
easy for Steve Israel to hate something
he was so demonstrably good at it's like
finding out this guy hates having bees
on his face I mean who's not wrong it's
absolutely repulsive it's just weird
that he chose to do it in the first
place and with his congressional career
coming to an end it was time to toe
Steve Israel in the most appropriate way
possible um I brought some Long Island
wine and I believe the traditional bag
the bathroom is that a 2016 does it go
back further the night
I wouldn't recommend drinking it out of
the bag Oh congressman I would never do
this to a glass not there come on the
bed sure that's fair yes what better way
to end a bittersweet career than with
the bittersweet taste of Northfork
Chardonnay savor every last drop steam
you